okay
in this uh
uh
i am going to i'm the one that's moving
him okay
so i'm moving him
in that pattern
that you are hitting with the other day
okay so moves him
oh
picks him up
[Music]
give me some
energy picks him up reconciles that
then enter turning his body into the
lock
here and i hold this weight in the mid
foot
boom
reconcile
and he can he can use me he's using me
to hold him up
so not like this
not just opening
i'm moving him
oh
reconcile
boom
he's using me
reconcile oh he uses me
reconcile
boom
he's using me
when he uses me that goes on midfoot
in it
to acquire skill at specific skill so
the point of any drill is to acquire a
skill
uh
there's there's only three marks
there's only three marks
substantial marks in ikea there's only
three and they're the same one
okay
so what are they do you remember
probably not
what do you what do you got
reconciliation
uh
i don't think that's one of them
one is the spontaneous uh manifestation
okay that's the third one what's the
second one
what's the first one
so you can see what dashi you are
okay you have all this access to
information
but it's just
okay
no
um
the reconciliation of the subject object
dichotomy
the mystical experience right
and the internal aspects
okay
uh
what do you think
i'm mainly doing here
of these three
which one
the internal aspects so this is a drill
supposed to work on what
the internal aspects now supposed to do
something else okay
so
um
that's why i said you're not opening up
right so i'm gonna have him pull
pull
got it okay he's gonna pull he's gonna
pull oh you see that okay he's pulling
so even if he's pushy
i still in his center that weight his
weight my weight is in my midfoot
i'm going from
it looks like i was controlling his
hands but i wasn't was that that's why
he can pull he's still coming in and
controlling his body okay
so tactically speaking
once i reconcile the young energy which
we'll put on the sideburner for now
what tactic tactically what am i
trying to get
anyway
what
no tactically what am i trying to
achieve
the body lock the body lock okay
so
uh when i come around
boom
we'll put this on the back burner and i
come in i move his whole body okay so
i'm gonna have him push he's gonna push
do you get it okay
and i'm just gonna move his whole body
do you understand
let's have him leave his feet where they
were which he did because he had the
intention do you see so he's
going to leave his feet where they are
it doesn't matter his whole body is
going gonna move
he'll go into the throw if he leaves his
feet where they are do you get it
so
i am letting him walk backwards in this
drill which i would not intentionally
do you understand that's why it's aikido
and not not it wasn't okay
so
how do i stop his feet from walking
backwards in
nagi waza
yep so displacing his stance with my
stance so i come this way
but in i tie so i won't do that
and he can now
keep his feet up
with his center that i've moved via the
body lock
okay
it's not him
stepping around me
do you understand that so see if you can
uh you go here and then you walk
backwards you walk back that that's not
it okay
i i do the body lock pull body lock and
then i let his stamps move his stats
do you get it but um
we'll rewind a little
i i have his body
do you understand
so in his body and we'll put that back
burner right here this is not where you
enter
you have to
contact his head so to speak
comes around
do you see
in and his weight is on me just more
weight he's holding on to me he's
holding on to me okay
in his body
here
reconcile
hit
he's holding on to me
okay
that's the drill try it again
okay so if i'm working
on my internal aspects
and he's working on his okay
and when he stops working on his you'll
see that the the drill will fall apart
okay
so if for example if i if i take the
elimination
and then he let's go
ryan where'd he go
he fell down do you see
so i'm doing i'm doing my drill right
and him
now bracing on me
you see or not really bracing on me but
grounding through me he can hang out
there all the time but if he if he
disconnects you you'll see okay
do you understand so
same thing happens here
uh
is i have the center and i go into the
body lock you see it see it right there
okay now if he drops his center then
he's going to fall
do you get it
now the drill stopped
it's like bench pressing and your
weights fell off the bar
okay
so
he allows himself
to be moved in
the body lock
boom
okay and here when i say he's holding on
to me i don't mean he's touching me he
can use me he he can brace on me
do you see he's bracing on me he's not
balancing there do you understand
do you understand you look confused
he's i'm holding him up do you
understand well not really holding him
up but
i'm taking his energy and grounding it
do you see and that helps condition me
so
we're here
right so as you watch
you see you can pick him up okay so it's
not him
getting there
and stretching his back
that's not it okay
all right
but if you drop your center the drill is
okay
uh you'll fall
let's try inject him out
boom body lock
the heel box
[Music]
it has to be that cadence
excuse me
okay let's go
okay so river he's working on what i'm
working on okay and when i do it
when i do a coq projection there's a
percussiveness to it
do you understand and burp this it's not
a matter of my arms moving there is a
percussiveness to the energy that's
coming coming in and out okay so when i
do the coke here part and i go here it's
not that i'm like pushing it you see
that there's an explosiveness
to
the movement
in here boom okay it's like you're going
to punch someone got it well his center
is going to do that same kind of
percussive
tension so here it's being bowed and as
i throw him he's gonna flex it
and through the ukemi so he doesn't bite
his head and all that kind of stuff so
he's flexing it okay
just like i previously flexed it so
pop pop
reflects it you see
so uh
just lower your butt and step back you
can see how different this is
he's not doing it
watch me i won't do it i'm just pushing
my hands
you see
so same percussiveness on both parties
okay
try it again